my name is David Sutherland
I'm the live producer at ice LA and
we're gonna play some propaganda in
chain-linked in your game not interact
see the design philosophy behind
dragon's teeth is infantry play focus on
infantry play but still not remove all
of the vehicles but this is this
battlefield after all this map in
particular not in this mode but in other
modes have tanks and it's very open in
this area that I'm running now as you
can see Shane link is basically a mix
between domination and conquest on the
infantry side it's quick captures and
then your points as you can see on the
bottom of the screen is counted on the
links you have enough the amount of
points or matter conquest flags or Flags
you have captured
so the strategy becomes a little bit
different especially since you can also
spawn on these flags so once you have a
flag you can spawn and your whole team
can from spawn so you can flip to flip
the game on pretty quickly in terms of
how it looks on the map and if you look
at the map you can see we have three
links and they have one that's being
contested right now so you want to break
the links obviously so if they were
smart now there you go for a or F to
break our points and this is also more
infantry focus so there's less vehicles
I think there's only transport vehicles
on this map it depends on the map a
little bit but you don't have the tanks
and don't have like any any flying
things or anything so it's more about
you and your squad and kind of like I
would say a big border to domination for
public play and yeah it's much more
fast-paced and it flows really well and
normally you can still get run over by a
team in this obviously but normally you
can always flank around and make them
suffer for not being able to defend
everything you get pinned up this as you
can see there's a lot of point so you
can't cover them all you can have to
pick your battles and pick the place
where you would be defend so now we're
playing sunken dragon in chain-link and
as you can tell it is pre drained this
area so this is a drained facility where
you control the dam which someone else
is trying to do and that will drain and
I'm not sure if you pressed it already
drain and fill the lake again see see
now it's drained which means this whole
building is listing and sitting on the
bottom of the lake and you fill it again
it stays there so it changes the
gameplay three times if you will so it
starts floating as a normal boat
restaurant would I've never seen one
that big but you know both restaurants
it floats there and then when you drain
it it ends up on the bottom and breaks
apart and you fill it again the water
fills up in the bottom level you can
swim in you get some jet skis instead
and so on so it's we're gonna make
changes gameplay and that's with all
these LEvolution the big ones at least
like this one and the other one we're
gonna see later they're all gameplay
effecting they change the way the map
place the way the way you would play it
as an infantry guy and I think that's
the big difference here and from an art
perspective I mean we looked at the big
one obviously the siege of Shanghai
skyscraper and we wanted something kind
of us
epic but also changing gameplay to to
that kind of degree without doing the
same thing again obviously that is
I will see on the map I think so this
map is a very organic map if I show the
map here you see it's very there's a
little little of this square rectangular
shapes that tend to be infantry map
focused because of buildings and roads
and like that
so this is a park and it's still an
infant to map it has this map is
probably a map that people they like to
snipe we're gonna like there's a lot of
elevated things on the map where you can
trace this this train station I'm going
to here you can kind of overlook the map
and do a lot of damage from afar but
also it has all these nooks and crevices
where you where you can hide and then I
wonder LEvolution hits it changes even
more drastically in that matter I also
have a lot of a lot of waterways where
you can take a jet skiing gonna
circumvent and go around the team the
other team and capture the flag for
instance which I believe would play -
that's a really good tactic to get to
where you wanna go quickly without
getting shut down that was the kind of
philosophy behind his map to a more
organic map that doesn't have all their
school hair buildings and it's not a
city per se there's a city around it
there's some city areas especially if
you play in conquest over there by G or
E I think but mainly its is fairly
logical Horton and we wanted to look
pristine I mean this is basically in the
in the storyline of this pack
the Chinese retreated from the coastal
cities of asia and left prison
at camps of you know refugee camps and
fortifications and stuff like that but
nothing's destroyed there's not been a
war here yet and we wanted to look you
know pristine I look at this little
meadow it's it's not been touched to it
so when you play the map you totally
change it from this pristine environment
to something very much muddy and and
they're broken
so this map front market is very
vertical and in this mode as you can see
the the points are very much squiggled
all over the map so you need to control
the vertical here you need to control
the groups and if you control the roofs
you control this map it's one of my
personal favorites because it has so
much micro destruction all this is it's
kind of like flood zone in that sense
has a lot of a rooftop destruction and
walls and stuff like that and you can
you play this map either you're gonna
love to play this like it's okay if you
know what I mean and because you have
action constantly it's very intense
pearl market in CTF actually we
implemented it if in the dragon's teeth
maps because it really suits the type of
gameplay we're after we want the team to
work together but we want it to be
infantry and infantry focused at least
it's not interview only I mean there's
vehicle but in this mode there is
transport vehicles and I believe that
transport car so you can at least defend
a little bit so this map is very
vertical and you have to kind of look
everywhere it's there's so many angles
it's either you played like a you know
you just running gun and running and
kind of use your twitch skills to to
maintain sanity or you try and play this
tactically and dominate the rooftops
probably the best way to do that would
be to snipe in this mode sniping
wouldn't be the best either
maybe if you
revive mr. Jack for this area so we have
we have a couple of new gadgets
especially the robots it's a battle
pickup and the reason for that is
because we want to make it powerful
without um that was in the game so
basically if it's a battle pick up you
can pick it up only in the mouse or
recruit it and in the modes that it
makes sense and works and doesn't
unbalance anything so therefore we can
make it more powerful we also want
people to use battle pickups the monster
or in the base game are they're there
but they're not really used that much at
least not as much as you would want to
so we kind of looked at that and saw
this as an opportunity to use battle
pickups more for the further stuff that
people want and obviously let me swap
over the ballistics shields is another
gadget that that really affects the game
and I faced a game in in general because
it's available as a gadget on the
support class which of course would be
playable on any map in the game so we
had we utilize the CTE for instance to
to be able to to run at least one test
round of the balance of that it had a
really powerful bash in the beginning
that we tweaked down because you could
run into room and kill everyone with the
shield the shield is it is a ballistic
shield so it stops bullet it doesn't
stop explosions and high-caliber stuff
so it's it's also that team play aspect
here we want you to play with this and
you be the shield in the turns have your
team behind you and get into that hairy
little tight spots metro and prison or
locker can it comes into mind or you can
break those stalemates if you know what
you're doing and have
spot with you the sniper rifle we added
is supposedly the best sniper rifle with
a silencer on it's short and it has a
lower velocity bullet and less range I
think for that reason but it is pretty
good on maps like this so the Bulldog
I'm not the weapons guy I don't know
anything about weapons I know about the
gameplay of the weapons but the Bulldog
is supposed to be the closer range
version of this bar if I don't recollect
incorrectly basically it's very
effective in in a closer range situation
and it's it has horizontal recoil more
horizontal recoil then as far as which
kicks up quite a lot so it's pretty
effective I have a suppressor on now so
I made it less subjective so let's go
into my favorites the assault so we have
two guns in this pack actually it's like
a different unlock tree as well we want
you to try both so you unlock the unica
first two and you use that to unlock the
Desert Eagle
because otherwise you people food has to
jump through this we go like unity
service and we don't believe it has it
has different uses I'm not the biggest
pistol player because I never play
weakened and
exactly what the differences are I know
that the deagle kicks a lot and does a
lot of damage but it kicks a lot it has
a lot of recoil so it's more of a
finisher offer or if you really good at
countering recoil you can use it as a
primary weapon or clear a sniper in
closer quarter combat the unica is also
kind of cheeky but it has a quicker fire
rate for sure and yeah it's my favourite
daughter too so that was dragon's teeth
dlc out for premium next week thanks for
watching
you